before they took over truTV and started
their search for Larry the Impractical
Jokers were once just a regular gang of
pranksters from Staten Island but what
did q Murr Sal and Joe do before TV
stardom from their beginnings in high
school through their days as the new
york-based comedy troupe the tenderloins
he is a look at the Impractical Jokers
before all the fame Catholics cool the
guys first met in a religion class at
Monster Nia Farrell an all-boys Catholic
High School in Staten Island
well they banded together and quickly
realized that the best way to meet girls
was through acting the one they weren't
acting they were pranking in a senior
year prank they called rice Capades the
guy's dumped ten pound bags of rice in
the school's hallways as cute old Fox
Sports students were slipping and
sliding in it's everywhere we had rice
fights it was a blast
took the janitorial crew weeks to get
all the rice out of the school let's put
the administration in no mood for FERPA
shenanigans so of course we pushed it
further later in the year
vermin day eventually earned cued
attention when he was caught putting a
goldfish in a toilet though that was
tame in comparison to the squirrels
crabs birds turtles and cats that were
released through to school that same day
both rice and cats would figure
prominently into their later pranks
there's so many places on my body to
hide to hide rice fold they have to fold
crevasse after crevasse I mean I get to
box there's no problem
Brian Quinn before he started his career
as a professional television Joker Brian
Quinn better known these days as Q was a
member of the New York City Fire
Department after taking a leave of
absence to film Impractical Jokers
he returned to the FDNY with a $50,000
donation but that didn't stop the
Joker's from mercilessly teasing him
about leaving his life of heroism behind
no I'm an actor on television as a kid
he was also obsessed with Star Wars and
forced his parents to take him to see
Return of the Jedi in theaters four
times hew still maintains his collection
of Star Wars toys today at one point Q
was engaged but it didn't go well did
you marry me okay but two weeks before
the wedding I'm gonna dunk you and marry
a cop he was almost a regular cast
member of comic book men having served
as one of Kevin Smith's first assistants
at the view sq offices and a host of the
tell em steve-dave podcast
fortunately for viewers Q's contract
with truTV made him stick with the
Joker's he was a fan of the tenderloins
before he was formally accepted as a
part of their crew as a replacement for
a departing member when the guys gave
him an opportunity to perform of them
comedic magic was made
oh I'm gonna kill everyone is dead James
Murray as a kid James Murray loved pro
wrestling and baseball his fondest
childhood sports memory was watching
Bobby the brain Heenan gets his teeth
smashed out by Hulk Hogan followed years
later seeing Roger Clemens from a broken
bat at Mike Piazza all live and in
person you probably know all about MERS
vocal talents from the show but he also
starred in multiple musicals throughout
his attendance at Georgetown and
eventually graduated with a BA in
English as fans may already know MERS
father was going to buy him a Ford
Taurus as a graduation gift
but merabh did for the $30,000 cash
instead so he could film a film project
a comedy about a modern teenage Jesus
the rest is TV history enjoy the next 50
minutes of your life I've tried to take
into account that you were young but
Olson Wells was in his 20s when he made
Citizen Kane what's your Excuse the
ambidextrous James Murray made a brief
appearance in the howard stern movie
private path as an extra and worked as a
TV producer on shows like say yes to the
dress
before humiliating himself on television
he maintains a simple life philosophy
here's my opinion life's too short not
to put everything in your mouth twice
yep once to see if you like it second
time you see if you're right about the
first time Salvatore vocano
as a kid Sal enjoyed playing basketball
football and hockey and later graduated
from Saint John's University with a
degree in finance while studying at st.
John's Sal starred in a comedic
mockumentary video series titled super
dude and friend Sal keeps his personal
life relatively private which is often a
subjective antagonism among his friends
before engaging in a life of self
humiliation Sal claims that his most
embarrassing moment was when his
babysitter saw him naked when he was 5
according to a reddit ask me anything at
one point in his early Joker's career
Sal was part owner of the full cup in
Staten Island though he since left the
business in addition to his humiliating
Jaden Smith tattoo his ink also includes
song lyrics dedicated to a deceased
friend and as merlyn's revealed Sal
cannot sleep without a sleep apnea
machine in his spare time Sal is known
to take women's pants hostage and send
creepy photos to their real owners
Joseph Gatto after attending high school
with the rest of the guys Joe got his
undergraduate degree in accounting from
Liu post just before going full-time
Joker
Joe worked as a personal shopper in a
baby store and today he's the only Joker
who's married and has a kid in addition
to pranks Gatos other true passion is
food
he's recalled how growing up in a large
Italian family there was always an
open-door policy for meals which
regularly included guests gatos food
fueled upbringing often translates into
his jokes and pranks today and despite
keeping his private life relatively
private Joe's wife has made regular
appearances on the show obviously you
know this is a game I have to kiss her
it means nothing you can kiss her if you
want to sleep on the couch getting the
gang back together the guys all went
their separate ways until one day Murr
ran into Sal on the ferry whether to
reminisce about their former improv days
inspiring them to get the group together
from there the guys practice their
sketches together in Joe's mom's
basement for six years at the time they
all have day jobs but we're having so
much fun performing for virtually no one
that they decided to take their
underground troupe to the next level in
1999 they formed the tenderloins because
the word tenderloin was something Sal
was uncomfortable saying in front of a
large group of people
oh god he's gonna say it to him he has
to time thugs the Impractical Jokers got
their first shot at stardom after
winning $100,000 on it's your show on
NBC a video submission contest hosted by
Carson Daly with a comedy clip titled
time thugs our skilled goons will travel
back through the time stream to
completely destroy anyone who might have
steered your life raw the newfound fame
and cash inspired the guys to take a
stab at TV filming a pilot for Spike TV
called mission uncomfortable spike
passed on the project but the undaunted
tenderloins began their evolution into
televisions of practical jokers piling
up a series of early gigs they even
included opening for imagine dragons as
a joke of course we're very happy to be
here opening for imagination dragon
opening for the imagination dragons
thanks for watching click the loop I
come to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know your love to
[Music]